tapant l'état monsieur dominique d'ordre
merci monsieur le président le premier
ministre alors que le chômage bat tête
hier un nouveau record historique
il y avait quelque chose d'indécent et
de pathétique à entendre vos ministres
continuez à nous dire qu'ils finiraient
bien par baisser ça fait trois ans en
effet que tel le coq chante clair dans
l'oeuvre d'un rostand le président de la
république lui même nous dit que grâce
aux mesures que vous prenez le jour va
finir par revenir sur la france et ça
fait trois ans que nous nous enfonçons
toujours plus dans la nuit le contexte
est pourtant favorable comme jamais la
banque centrale européenne nous sert sur
un plateau un euro un niveau
historiquement bas
grâce aux liquidités qu'elle injecte les
marchés financiers que vous détestez
tant vous offre des taux d'intérêt
jamais connu et le pétrole est au plus
bas
c'est donc bien à cause de votre
politique que les français sont privées
et fruits de cette croissance inespérée
et vous proposez quoi
cent mille emplois subventionnés de plus
et pourquoi pas trois millions
vous avez matraquer les ménages vous
avez matraquer les entreprises la
matraque et les collectivités et vous
proposez ne rien changer du tout vous
avez cassé en même temps la consommation
et l'investissement et on change rien
notre marché du travail est d'une
rigidité édité inouïe et on ne change
toujours rien monsieur le premier
ministre les français sont désespérés et
ils ont bien compris quant à eux que le
jour ne reviendra sur la france que le
jour où vous partirez entre le chant du
coq sin est si fier si péremptoire et le
chant du cygne ils ont fait leur choix
merci la parole est à monsieur françois
rebsamen minutieux travail de l'emploi
et de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés
monsieur le député dominique dord si
vous aviez un bilan excellent que vous
veniez aujourd'hui donner des leçons
cela se comprendrait mais inlassablement
écoute un mois après mois re mois après
mois depuis 2008 le chômage a augmenté
et c'est ainsi que sous votre présidence
sous la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
le chômage a augmenté de 750 milles
depuis le mois d'août 2008 jusqu'en 2012
et je ne compte pas les chômeurs que
vous avez laissé en partant au mois de
mai 2012 à travers tous les plans
sociaux que vous n'avez pas eu le
courage d'assumer et que vous avez
repoussé comme le déclarait lui-même
l'ancien premier ministre monsieur
fillon
alors quelle est la réalité aujourd'hui
la réalité est la suivante la
conjoncture économique s'améliore
incontestablement vous pouvez on
croirait que cela est pour vous un
moment désagréable que d'entendre cela
effectivement
effectivement les chiffres sont là la
croissance du premier trimestre a été de
+0 6 ce qui est supérieur à la moyenne
des autres pays européens
vous le savez très bien la croissance du
pouvoir d'achat l'année dernière était
de +2 1% mais
ce sont les chiffres continuer à
vociférer elle ça ne changera rien à
l'explication que je vais vous donner et
vous savez très bien qu'il y à un
décalage entre la croissance vécu sur le
terrain et la création d'emplois c'est
pourquoi à travers votre question c'est
un message d'espoir que je voudrais
envoyer aux françaises et aux français
oui le gouvernement agit et vous avez
tort de vous manquer les emplois aidés
quand on sait comment vous les avez
utilisé merci monsieur le ministre